A SEMI TRUCK OVERTURNED NEAR
ATLANTA YESTERDAY, AND SPILLED
40,000 POUNDS OF BROCCOLI ON TO
THE HIGHWAY.
SAID ONE RESPONDING OFFICER,
FLORET!
[ AUDIENCE GROANS ]
THIS BRINGS US TO A NEW SEGMENT
CALLED "ONE OF MY WRITERS
EXPLAINS A JOKE."
♪♪♪
SO IAN, YOU WANT TO EXPLAIN THAT
JOKE?
>> YEAH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO YOU KNOW HOW THE LITTLE TREE
PART OF THE BROCCOLI -- IT'S
CALLED THE FLORET?
>> Seth: YEAH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> UH -- AND ALSO, IF YOU WANT
TO GO SOMEWHERE FAST IN A CAR --
[ LAUGHTER ]
YOU MIGHT SAY "FLOOR IT?"
>> Seth: YEAH.
NOW, OBVIOUSLY, WHEN I READ THAT
JOKE, I KNEW THAT, BECAUSE YOU,
IN THE PUNCHLINE, SPELLED FLORET
F-L-O-R-E-T, BUT SINCE THEY
SOUND THE SAME, DID YOU REALLY
THINK THE ENTIRE AUDIENCE WOULD
JUMP TO THE CONCLUSION THAT YOU
MEANT THE BROCCOLI FLORET?
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> WELL IN MY MIND, THE POLICE
OFFICER WANTED TO GET TO THE
EMERGENCY QUICKLY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BUT HE ALSO SAW BROCCOLI.
AND SO AS A REQUEST, AND ALSO AS
A WARNING --
[ LAUGHTER ]
HE SAID, "FLORET."
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> THIS HAS BEEN, "ONE OF MY
WRITERS EXPLAINS A JOKE."
>> Seth: YOU GUYS HAVE REALLY
SET ME BACK BY APPLAUDING FOR
THAT.
[ LAUGHTER ]